that's a foul to kill first in the last  two minutes everybody's excited though  the battles with Luca bands are all  fired up again with Turkey for both  those guys right now  Wow  second of all he's got thrown out he  waived off the officials he gave the  official to waive off and he just got  tossed  [Applause]  sure  now goes Bradley Beal with 109 left at a  seven-point game  [Applause]  get Luca chance was 33rd point of the  game  [Applause]  and he missed that great though the  massive his to technical foul  free-throws here last little bit so they  were both call for double technicals  right there  [Music]  Jonathan sterling has made the  indication then watched Beal right there  that way